Avengers in-game re-release is
officially back in theaters and with it
we got a new tribute to Stan Lee a new
Hulk deleted scene that serves as a
post-credits scene now and a new clip
from spider-man far from home and as you
just saw the clip offers a little bit
more clarification about one scene that
we actually thought were two scenes
leading up to this clip and there's also
some important talk between agent Hill
and Nick Fury so we're gonna go ahead
and break this clip down also if you
would like a chance to win a Captain
America shield and Iron Man helmet and
Infinity Gauntlet or another Marvel
Legends item be sure to subscribe to my
channel I'm picking 3 winners from my
giveaway at four hundred and fifty
thousand subscribers so as you can see
the scene starts off in Mexico they're
going to investigate a natural disaster
they find out that a cyclone has hit
this small city that agent Hill has no
idea why they're there their shield
agents they're not supposed to
investigate things like natural
disasters but then Nick Fury says that
he heard from some of the locals reports
that the cyclone had a face but agent
Hill just sort of writes it off and says
a lot of people see things when they're
under stress but then she says that that
does not mean that this is the start to
some other big world and then she gets
cut off because Mysterio shows up but
what is basically happening here is that
agent Hill does not want to believe that
something major is happening to the
world why because the snap just happened
in this film she was just brought back
to life after being dusted same thing
with fury and same thing with Peter
Parker we know that this movie takes
place right after the events of Avengers
endgame so Tony Stark just died and
everybody that was snapped by Thanos
just got brought back by Professor Hulk
so the world and the universe was just
devastated they just dealt with Fanus
attack and they don't want to have to go
through anything else threatening the
earth and that's going to be a big part
of the movie specifically with Peter
Parker we know that in this movie he's
just going to want to be a normal
teenager and go on a date with MJ but
sadly the cyclone was an elemental and
Peter is going to have to fight them in
spider-man far from home but then we see
Mysterio show up and this is the first
time that he's met Nick Fury and agent
Hill when he shows up he asked who are
you and then immediately the sand
elemental shows up Nick Fury and Maria
hill start firing at the elemental but
obviously the bullets do nothing and
then Mysterio starts to attack saying
you don't want any part of this now the
way the trailers made this look made it
seem like Mysterio is showing up in this
scene to save spider-man and he says you
don't want any part of this kid but
classic marvel misdirection but this is
when Mysterio and Nick Fury and agent
Hill meet for the very first time and in
this scene Mysterio probably saves their
lives somehow from the sand elemental
and that's when they start to work
together
fury until will obviously ask who
Mysterio is which is when Mysterio will
tell them the story of another dimension
and the elementals which of course will
lead to Mysterio working for shield and
then the recruitment of Peter Parker and
that's it for the clip this is how
Mysterio meets Nick Fury and Maria hill
it's not in a way that most people would
have thought but now we officially know
so again this was the clip that was
shown at the Avengers in-game re-release
after the credits it was leaked online
be sure to comment and let me know what
you think about this also comment with
your favorite superhero or villain like
this video and subscribe to my channel
so you can enter my giveaway and as
always thank you all so much for
watching Wolf Wolf